[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed you know I bet that
you'd be fine without me hello everybody
welcome to the minimalists podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less
my name is Joshua fields Milburn and I
just want to welcome you to episode
number 40 it's hard to believe that
we've done 40 episodes of the minimalist
podcast this year and what you're about
to hear is a special edition of our
podcast last year Ryan and I published a
book called essential essays by the
minimalists it was really the best of
the minimalist it's a 150 essays that we
have published over the last five or six
years about twelve different topics
everything from minimalism and stuff and
decluttering to finances and Technology
and relationships and health and
mindfulness and success and everything
in between so we've written well over
500 essays and you can read all of those
for free on our website but what Ryan
and I wanted to do was give you a bunch
of those essays in audio form as well so
that book came out last year in 2015 and
now it's finally available as an
audiobook which you can check out on
iTunes and Amazon and audible but we
also wanted to give you a free version
of that audio book here on the podcast
so this is not an excerpt or a sample
necessarily this is the first hour and
15 minutes of that book it goes through
the intro of the book and then two major
subjects from the book both minimalism
and stuff so it's the first two chapters
from the book so you'll get some value
from these first two chapters and the by
the way is read by our very talented
narrator his name is Justin Moloch and
he hosts a wonderful podcast called
optimal living daily you can check that
out we'll put that in the show notes for
you as well but we really hope you enjoy
these first two chapters the our first
hour and 15 minutes of the audiobook
Forrest
if you want to listen to the entire
6-hour unexpurgated version of the book
you can do that we'll put a link to that
in the show notes as well or you can
just search for essential over at
audible itunes or amazon here it is the
first hour or so of essential essays by
the minimalists i hope you enjoy
essential essays by the minimalists by
joshua fields Milburn and Ryan Nicodemus
read by Justin Moloch music by we
[Music]
simplicity is the ultimate
sophistication Leonardo da Vinci chapter
1 minimalism inside the prison walls of
consumerism there's a shopping mall in
San Diego that used to be a prison
restored repurposed and redecorated it's
hard to imagine this place once
imprisoned hundreds of inmates one might
argue however it's a different kind of
prison now a voluntary incarceration
caged by the invisible walls of
consumption
this might sound hyperbolic but it's an
apt analogy consumption isn't the
problem
compulsory consumption is we've trapped
ourselves by thinking consumerism will
make us happy that buying crab we don't
need will somehow make us whole we've
gotten good at fooling ourselves too
we've over-decorated the jailhouse walls
walls we built around ourselves and
we've made our cells so comfortable
we're terrified to leave but a prison
cell with a view is still a prison cell
perhaps there's a key to our escape what
is minimalism at first glance people
might think the point of minimalism is
only to get rid of material possessions
eliminating jettisoning extracting
detaching decluttering paring down
letting go that's a mistake though
removing the excess is an important part
of the recipe but it's just one
ingredient if we're concerned solely
with the stuff then we're missing the
larger point minimalists don't focus on
how
less less less rather we focus on making
room for more more more more time more
passion more experiences more growth
more contribution more contentment and
more freedom it just so happens that
clearing the clutter from life's path
helps us make that room minimalism is a
thing that gets us past the things so we
can make room for life's important
things which actually aren't things at
all
there are many flavors of minimalism a
20 year old single guy's minimalist
lifestyle looks different from a 45 year
old mother's minimalist life even though
everyone embraces minimalism differently
each path leads to the same place a life
with more meaning the irony of
minimalism a word of warning as you
consider simplifying your life if you
call yourself a minimalist or if you
tell people you are interested in
minimalism then everything you do will
instantly be steeped in irony oh you
drive a car that's not very minimalist
of you wait you have more than one pair
of shoes hypocrite you own a blow-dryer
phony what these people don't understand
however is minimalism is not about
deprivation it's about finding more
value in the stuff you own minimal let's
do this by removing the superfluous
keeping only the possessions that serve
a purpose or bring joy everything else
goes by the wayside
there is no minimalist rulebook we're
all different the things that add value
to one person's life may not add value
to yours so hold on to that hair
straighteners those colorful socks that
collection of angel statuettes but only
if they are appropriate for your life
people will judge let them judgement is
but a mirror reflecting the insecurities
of the person who's doing the judging
simple isn't radical sometimes people
avoid minimalism because the word is
self sounds extreme radical subversive
afraid of stepping outside cultural
boundaries these people avoid
simplifying their lives because they
don't want the label minimalist if
minimalism seems too austere then
perhaps you can real able your flavor of
simplification maybe suggest any of the
following isms enough ISM essentialism
selective ISM curation ISM naturalism
stoicism epicureanism appropriate ISM
simple ISM less ISM practical ISM living
within your means ISM call it whatever
you want
no matter which is um you favor the
important part is it helps you live with
intention is minimalism only for single
rich white guys someone in Montreal
asked us this question granted she
posited it more congenial e than written
above but restated this way we get to
the heart of the matter we won't bother
detailing the many examples that
immediately torpedo this assumption our
friend Leo ba bada and his six kids
Tammy Strobel and her tiny house Patrick
rone and his family and others none of
whom are single nor rich nor white guys
and yet they all embrace a minimalist
lifestyle note you can read more about
minimalist families including additional
books and resources at the minimalist
com forward slash children let's look at
the question from a broader perspective
the Bureau of Labor Statistics shows
that in today's economy quote is
entirely possible for poor people to
have much of the same material comforts
cars televisions computers smartphones
as more affluent people yet be trapped
in low-paying jobs with little prospect
of improvement
unquote in other words rich people and
poor people can both be oppressed by the
possessions they desire however poor
people are considerably more stifled
because of their lesser quote unquote
prospect of improvement perhaps
minimalism is the quote unquote prospect
of improvement whenever desire is
greater than one's ability to attain
discontentment sets in by mitigating our
impulse to compulsively consume however
we take back control of our desires as
well as our pocketbooks according to the
New York Times there is evidence that
quote money relieves suffering in cases
of true
you'll need but when money becomes an
end in itself it can bring misery to
unquote once our basic human needs are
met money doesn't buy happiness
and neither does poverty people with
fewer resources especially those with
less money can benefit most from
minimalism a minimalist lifestyle helps
people determine what truly adds value
to their lives this is even more
important when our resources are limited
if we have less money then we must be
more intentional with how we spend it
simplification baguettes intentionality
rich or poor married or single black or
white simplifying one's life can only
benefit one circumstances the Stoics
understood this as it the ROE Gandhi
Jesus and the Buddha it sure would be
nice if everyone else did to the gospel
of less no minimalism is not a religion
religion is a complicated and sensitive
subject for many even though we don't
typically speak or write about religion
his presence seems to loom over each
event we host curiosity is natural so
it's inevitable people often approach us
and say things like it's wonderful to
see two guys spreading Jesus Christ's
message which is usually followed by
another person saying it's great to see
a couple of Buddhists sharing their
story or did you know Muhammad was the
original minimalist in a well written
but unfortunately title newspaper
article in Tennessee we were recently
said to be quote spreading the gospel of
less unquote the connotation of which is
a bit troubling even more troubling was
a radio host take in Oklahoma City when
he referred to us as the quote l ron
Hubbard of minimalism unquote thankfully
he was joking whatever your religious
beliefs we have no spiritual advice for
you the beautiful thing about minimalism
though is it works whether you're
religious or not we personally know
minimalist who are Christian pastors
minimalist who are practicing Buddhist
minimalist were atheists we even know a
minimalist rabbi because minimalism is a
lifestyle that helps people question
what things add value to their lives
it applies to any religion or no
religion at all in fact the two of us
hold radically different religious
beliefs our journeys towards simplicity
however had nothing to do with religion
instead it was a reaction to the
discontentment we experienced after
being steeped in consumerism for three
decades we live in a world in which many
people have different beliefs different
faiths
God or no God we could all live more
deliberately about the minimalists for
us Joshua Ryan it all started with a
lingering discontent a few years ago
while approaching age 30 we had achieved
everything that was supposed to make us
happy
great six-figure jobs nice cars big
houses with more bedrooms and
inhabitants pointless masses of toys
skies of superfluous stuff and with all
that stuff we weren't satisfied with our
lives we weren't happy there was a
gaping void and working 70 to 80 hours a
week for a corporation and buying even
more stuff didn't fill the void it only
brought more debt and stress and anxiety
and fear and loneliness and guilt and
overwhelm and depression we didn't
control our time and we didn't control
our lives so in 2010 we took back
control using the principles of
minimalism to focus on what's important
on December 14th 2010 we started the
minimalist calm as a way to share our
story in 2011 we left our corporate
careers at age 30 to pursue something
more meaningful after publishing our
first book minimalism live a meaningful
life a book about the five pillars of
minimalism we became contributing to
people through writing classes and
private mentoring sessions we have been
fortunate to establish an online
audience of millions of readers and our
stories been featured in The New York
Times Wall Street Journal Forbes USA
Today National Post Time magazine Today
Show and hundreds of other media outlets
the Boston Globe referred to our story
as quote Henry David Thoreau but with
Wi-Fi on a quote we have spoken at
Harvard Business School Apple and
several large conferences South by
Southwest TEDx world domination summit
as well as many smaller venues including
colleges corporate groups libraries soup
kitchens and various nonprofit
organizations note you can watch our
TEDx talk at the minimalist com4 slash
TEDx toward the end of 2012 we moved
from our hometown Dayton Ohio to a cabin
outside Phillipsburg Montana as a four
month experiment we followed this with a
move in 2013
- beautiful Missoula Montana where we
co-founded asymmetrical press a
publishing house for the indie at heart
in 2014 we published a best-selling
memoir everything that remains and
donated a year of our lives to a hundred
city tour traveling the globe to share
our met
more than 100 free events in E countries
as of this writing our newest project
minimalism a documentary about the
important things a feature-length film
directed by Matt D Avella in association
with catalysts asymmetrical inspire
media is in post-production and will be
in theaters and online soon more details
at minimalism film comm this is only the
radically condensed version of our story
included here not to impress anyone but
rather to establish a context for this
book should you want to you can read the
full version of our minimalist journeys
and our aforementioned memoir everything
that remains this book however is
different about this book since we
started our website we have written
hundreds if not thousands of essays
about a wide array of topics ranging
from simple living and cultivating
passion to writing publishing
entrepreneurship health relationships
personal growth and contribution in that
time many people asked us to collect our
favorite essays from the blog and
organize them in book form which
resulted in three short essay
collections early on the minimalists
2011 simplicity 2012 and a day in the
life of a minimalist 2013 however in an
effort to simplify our catalogue we
decided we should combine all three
books trim the fat from those
collections and add some of our most
important recent essays effectively this
book is the best of the minimalists but
it's not a book book it's more like a
well curated website made available in
print and ebook formats
collected here are the most relevant
essays some short some long from our
website
most of these essays were written by us
together however in the cases in which
an essay was written solo is accompanied
by a byline crediting either Joshua or
Ryan for his authorship parsed into
twelve important themes this collection
has been edited and organized into an
order that creates an experience
appreciably different from reading blog
posts online by bringing our best work
together into one tome we removed any
obvious redundancies although we
intentionally kept certain necessary
repetitions to reinforce important
points
eg phrases such as add value contribute
beyond yourself and meaningful life
appear with some frequency throughout
these pages each time to reiterate our
core principles however these are
individual essays while we organize this
book in a deliberate manner
is not meant to function as a linear
narrative rather this book is meant to
serve as a conversation in two ways
first as a continuous conversation
between the author's Joshua Ryan in the
reader and second as a conversation
starter between the reader and the
people in their life every essay that
follows is a single standalone
ingredient our intent is to provide all
the ingredients you need to create your
own recipe for an extraordinary life
constructing an extraordinary life an
extraordinary life doesn't just happen
it is constructed crafted curated we
ought not simply go with a flow then
going with the flow is nice and easy for
a while writing the current wherever it
might take us but eventually everyone
ends up at the same place the rapids and
then unprepared we're in for a world of
hurt your two authors both have
extraordinary lives were not ashamed to
admit this it wasn't always this way
though for the longest time our lives
were unremarkable at best miserable at
worst too long we went with the flow as
a result we were fat in debt and
unfulfilled by the lies we were leading
lies filled with every conceivable type
of clutter mental clutter emotional
clutter physical clutter we had reached
the rapids and we were quickly headed
for the Falls then we decided to change
an extraordinary life a life to be proud
of is a decision not a single decision
but a myriad of little decisions each
day daily decisions about money and
health and passion and contribution one
day at a time these decisions add up
until one day you look over your
shoulder and realize you've created an
extraordinary life whom this book is for
your two authors have learned more than
we ever dreamed throughout our journey
into minimalism and we're still learning
the most important lesson we've learned
though is minimalism appeals to only one
group of people people with an open mind
during our coast-to-coast travels we've
experienced a diverse group of people
thousands people have attended our
events from factory workers to CEOs from
attorneys to stand-up comics from
eleven-year-old boys to e
three-year-olds great-grandmother's from
every ethnicity to every socio-economic
background from high school dropouts to
college professors from marathon runners
to people struggling to lose weight from
single moms to parents bringing their
teenagers to here
a simpler life minimalism is applicable
to anyone anyone with an open mind we're
all searching for meaningful lives you
are not alone not utopia but a better
world
no minimalism will not solve all your
problems
unfortunately people sometimes believe
the goal of simple living is to own as
few possessions as possible to declutter
our homes to organize our lives and to
clear our minds once we do this we'll
each find our utopia and bask in the
glory of newfound happiness right not
exactly real life doesn't work this way
minimalism is not the end game it is not
the result
chucking your material possessions does
not necessarily equal happiness you
could get rid of all your stuff and
still be miserable getting rid of the
excess in your life will however help
you discover what does make you happy
hint it's not your possessions most of
your possessions are actually in the way
of your happiness it's much easier to
find the path toward happiness once
you've cleared the debris minimalism
will never lead you to your utopia life
will always have its moments of tedium
drudgery sadness and pain but minimalism
can lead you to a better life one that's
more exciting fulfilling satisfying and
rewarding you can start small but it's
worth getting started today after you
read this book which is organized to be
read in small chunks when I say at a
time you can find additional free
resources games photos podcasts and
videos to help you plan your journey at
the minimalist calm let's begin shall we
chapter two stuff consumption is not the
problem we all need some stuff many of
us take it too far though the average
American household contains more than
300 thousand possessions we've
accumulated more than we need in hopes
they'll make us happy in some
hypothetical future but it won't we know
this needing more will always lead to a
pall of desire until we feel trapped by
consumption purchasing more stuff to
make us happy
following consumerism broken template is
a real issue not consumption the
solution then is to consume deliberately
to ignore the [ __ ] advertisements
and determine
we need based on our own lives not what
we've been told we need we're all
different
what we need is different for each of us
you are what you desire every whole
person has wants cravings aspirations we
all desire something we don't however
all have the same desires some of us
long to create something purposeful to
make a difference in the world to eschew
the so-called American Dream in favor of
something better something more
deliberate and experience driven life of
intentionality instead of a life pushed
toward the wrong side of the consumption
continuum on the other hand some of us
watch the luminous box flickering in our
living rooms and yearn for the material
things in its advertisements the things
that bring a stress discontent and often
keep us tied to a particular income
which keeps us tied to jobs we don't
love or worse jobs we hate also we can
obtain the shiny objects projected on
the glowing rectangle in truth most of
us desire both we desire the experiences
and the stuff usually the latter gets in
the way of the former too often our
material desires get in the way of a
more meaningful life we are what we
desire
the rats in the tunnel there's a light
at the end of the tunnel we all know
this even when it's hard to find we know
it's there just beyond the bend
finding the light isn't the hardest part
of life's journey it's dealing with
what's hiding in the tunnel what lurks
in the darkness keeps us from focusing
on the light
anytime we visit New York City we might
see oversized rats scurrying down the
blackened train tracks below the subway
platform if we jump down and walk those
tracks we will find the light at the end
of the subway tunnel
eventually finding the light isn't what
worries us what worries us are the rats
in the tunnel
we must contend with whatever stalks the
darkness what waits to trip us up and
keep us from the light the rats are no
different from the plethora of obstacles
getting in our way every day the mundane
tasks the banal distractions the vapid
harmful ways we pacify ourselves
minimalism allows us to remove those
obstacles and focus on the lights it
allows us to shoo the rats from the
tunnel and find the light more quickly
minimalism allows us to swiftly exit the
tunnel and avoid the malevolent filthy
creatures lurking in the darkness and
the light is so much brighter when you
get out of the tunnel
what are your rats what keeps you in the
tunnel hidden from the light shopping
television internet debt clothes gadgets
and consumer electronics overeating
something else what can you get rid of
to focus on the light
what can you remove from your life to
make it more meaningful
adequate you are inadequate at least
that's what advertisers would like you
to believe you bear witness to proof of
your inadequacy everyday you see it on
your TV hear it on your radio stare back
at it on your computer screen and on
highway billboards there are plenty of
messages all around you to reinforce
your utter inadequacy
if you're a male you're not a real man
unless you drink this brand of beer and
eat this particular cut of meat and
drive this brain of sport utility
vehicle and if you're a female you're
not a real woman unless you squeeze into
this size dress and Don this shiny piece
of jewelry and tow to this purse with
all the ostentatious sees or LVS on his
leather exterior then and only then will
you feel adequate or so they'd have you
believe but when you obtain these things
what happens do you feel long-term
adequacy no of course not your thirst
for overindulge consumption isn't
quenched when you obtain more material
possessions it's just the opposite your
desire to consume increases you've set
the bar higher and thus the threshold
for future satisfaction is higher it's a
vicious cycle consumption is an
unquenchable thirst you create that
thirst you manufacture the desire to
consume more advertisers play their role
they help activate the desire you create
but ultimately the desire is yours to
control once you realize you have
control you can break the cycle you can
avoid the continuous downward spiral
there's one way out of consumption
spiral we must realize the things we
purchase do not define who we are unless
we allow them to if we are defined by
our things we will never be happy but if
we are defined by our actions then we'll
have the opportunity to feel fulfilled
by our everyday growth we'll have the
opportunity to feel satisfied with our
everyday contribution to others and
we'll have the opportunity to be content
every day of our lives the stuff doesn't
make you happy you make you happy
how we woke up every mouth is drawn to
light even when that light is a flame
hot burning flickering the fire
tantalizing the drab creature with its
bluish white illumination but when the
moth flies too close to the flame we all
know what happens it gets burned
incinerated by the very thing that drew
an ear for decades now we consumers have
been moths lured by the blue flame of
consumerism pop culture's beautiful
conflagration a firestorm of lust and
greed and wanting a solipsistic desire
to consume that which cannot be consumed
to be fulfilled by that which can never
be fulfilling a vacant proposition
leaving us empty inside for the fueling
the blaze of lust and greed and wanting
from our intimate vantage points within
reach of the flames scorching edges the
fire seems impossible to extinguish
unlike the moth though we have a choice
it is not an easy choice the flame is
ever more intriguing advertisers make
sure of this it is their job to find new
ways to make the blaze eternally more
appealing some of us recognize a need
for change others know change is
necessary but refused to stop circling
the mesmerizing flame they can't remove
their eyes from the spill of electric
light illuminating their homes still
others don't realize it's a flame at all
how could something so beautiful be so
dangerous so they circle the inferno
unconscious of its dangers we must
however accept the flame for what it is
necessary beautiful and most of all
dangerous when we do this when we step
back to understand the nature of the
fire we have a chance to survive this
takes deliberate thoughts repeated
questioning of the way we live a
thorough understanding of why we feel
comforted by the flame it is difficult
to do but this is how we wake up haunted
by desire the ghosts of desperation lust
and envy hide in the shadow of our
yearning be it money material
possessions or accolades we are haunted
by our aspirations covet that shiny new
truck that next big promotion that
beautiful man or woman and you will feel
unspeakable pain until it he or she is
yours when your desires met however your
flame is not extinguished you're filled
with new desires it's a never-ending
cycle
the key then is to aspire towards
something worthwhile
instead of jonesing for things we must
pursue those which are without
definitive milestones growth
contribution love these qualities are
self fulfilling seek growth and you will
grow endeavor to give to others and you
will contribute love others in your cup
will overflow it is not wrong to have
aspirations desires goals but it is
wrong for us to imagine we can ever see
she ate our ever-growing need for more
in too deep it's easy to believe Earth
turns slowly on its axis it's always
there we're a part of it deep in the
middle of its rotation in many ways
consumerism is the same way it's all
around us everywhere we turn seemingly
unstoppable hell's self consuming heart
but earth doesn't turn slowly it's
spinning at over a thousand miles an
hour
this became easy for us to understand
once we step back and paid attention
also became aware of our surroundings
similarly we needn't look around at all
this mass consumption and overindulgence
and believe it's normal it's not things
haven't always been this way this
chaotic this meaningless and the future
need to be either a sunrise is on the
horizon and we can see it once we open
our eyes become more aware of what's
important and realize we're in too deep
minimalism scares the [ __ ] out of me by
Ryan Nicodemus minimalism scares the
[ __ ] out of you
you're worried you'll get rid of stuff
you'll need later you're worried what
your friends your family your co-workers
and your neighbors will think of you
you're worried you'll lose your identity
your status and everything you've given
meaning to in your life me too
minimalism still scares the [ __ ] out of
me I know there are many people who are
as scared as me and I'm here to tell you
that's okay I've always been the type of
person who puts his whole heart into his
beliefs when I take on a particular
ideal or a way of life I make the most
of it I do this to a fault I have such
high expectations of myself that I often
expect perfection which probably why I
stress out easier than most why more
anxiety than most on top of the
expectations a lot of people around me
love to point out every non minimal
thing I have in my life they love to
talk about how I own a condo where nice
shoes and have a nice haircut yes
someone actually brought up my haircut
and the list goes on and on but these
people are only projecting they feel as
though I'm judging them because I don't
live the way they do anymore
you might be thinking Ryan why do you
care what people think
it's not about my caring as much as
these people reaffirming negative things
I already think about myself with the
exception of my haircut which I'm quite
fond of thank you very much I'm aware
there are many things in my life I still
need to minimize the simplifying process
like life is ever-changing minimalism is
fluid as our circumstances change our
versions of the simple life must change
too
the beautiful thing about minimalism is
there is no right or wrong
there is no pace at which you must live
your life and there's nothing that says
this is how you have to live minimalism
is a journey and it is scary for
everyone
decluttering doesn't work like that
decluttering is by and large a farce if
you picked up this book to figure out
how to declutter your closet you're in
the wrong place you'll be hard-pressed
to find anything here even vaguely
resembling something as trite as 67 ways
to declutter a messy home that's because
decluttering alone doesn't solve the
problem discussing how to get rid of
your stuff answers only the what but not
the why the what ie
the how-to is easy we all know
instinctually how to declutter you can
start small focus on one room at a time
making progress each day as you work
toward a simplified life you can go big
rent a dumpster and throw out everything
moving on to a more fulfilling life or
you can take the moderate approach
plunge into a packing party embrace the
fun side of decluttering enjoying the
entire simplification process people
should however be more concerned with
the why the purpose behind decluttering
than the what while the what is easy the
why is far more obscure because the
nature of the why is highly individual
ultimately it has to do with the
benefits you'll experience once you're
on the other side of decluttering
decluttering is not the end result it is
merely the first step you don't become
instantly happy and content by just
getting rid of your stuff at least not
in the long run decluttering doesn't
work like that
if you simply embrace the what without
the Y then you'll get nowhere slowly and
painfully by the way repeatedly making
the same mistakes it is possible to get
rid of everything you own and still be
utterly miserable to come home to your
empty house and soak after removing all
your pacifiers when you get rid of the
vast majority of your possessions you're
forced to confront your darker side when
did I give so much meaning to material
possessions what is truly important in
life why am i discontent who is this
person I want to become how will i
define my own success these are
difficult questions with no easy answers
but these questions are far more
important than just ditching your
material possessions if you don't answer
them carefully rigorously then the
closet you just decluttered will be
brimming with new purchases not long
from now
organizing is well-planned hoarding we
need to start thinking of organizing as
a dirty word it is a sneaky little
profanity that keeps us from simplifying
our lives our televisions would have us
believe there's a battle being fought on
the consumption continuum a battle
between the organizers and the orders
and from our couches it's hard to see
who's winning we posit to you these two
sides are working together colluding to
achieve the same thing the accumulation
of more stuff one side the orders done
so overtly leaving everything out in the
open making them easy targets to sneer
at but the other side the sneaky
organizers are more covert more
systematic more devious when it comes to
the accumulation of stuff ultimately
though organizing is nothing more than
well-planned hoarding sure both sides go
about their hoarding differently but the
end result is not appreciably different
whether our homes are strewn with
wall-to-wall material possessions or we
have a complex or null item dispersal
system color-coded and alphabetize we're
still not dealing with the real problem
no matter how organized we are we must
continue to care for the stuff we
organize cleaning and sorting our
methodically structured belongings when
we get rid of the superfluous stuff we
can focus on life's more important
aspects we can spend the day focusing on
our health on our relationships on
pursuing our passions or we can
reorganize the basement again once the
excess stuff is out of the way staying
organized is much easier
a short guide to getting rid of your
crap by Joshua fields Melbourne and
Julian Smith yay it's Friday time to
head home and relax after a week of hard
work step one and to the front door of
your home toss off your shoes notice
sitting behind the door a pair of booty
of worn only once shrug step two turn on
the television and sit on your ikea
couch attempt to relax awake in 20
minutes later realizing you've been
passively flipping through channels turn
off the TV and remove the batteries from
your remote toss them in your Blendtec
blender stop yourself moments away from
doing something drastic step 3 briefly
fondle the iPhone in your pocket stop
yourself realizing you're about to do
the exact same thing with YouTube as you
did with TV delete every unnecessary app
from your phone step 4
wonder what people did before television
and Internet access
observe the room around you looking over
the unread books and unwatched DVDs
lining your dusty shelves consider
shopping then picture the unworn clothes
occupying your cavernous walk-in closet
step 5
realize your imagination has turned all
black and gray the creativity drained
from your life step 6
suddenly recognize you haven't used your
spare room ever [ __ ] do the math and
realize said room is costing you 5 or 6
hours of work per month take out a piece
of paper and compare it to that trip to
Europe you've been meaning to take stare
at the math and disbelief stuff the
paper in your mouth and begin to chew
step 7 realize the brief emotional rush
that accompany the purchase of each item
in your home is now gone leaving only
the object itself in its most basic
uninteresting form the gorgeous pastel
designer couch has become simply a chair
a beautiful glass buffet is transformed
into a mere table a set of immaculate
handmade dishes has aged into nothing
but a bunch of plates your goose down
duvet is actually just a blanket wince
step eight glance down at your groceries
and realize the Doritos lays and ruffles
you purchased are nothing but colored
corn and potatoes step 9
open your credit card bill wide-eyed
discover how often you've confused
shopping with actual extracurricular
activities consider joining a monastery
step 10 remember that time you went over
to a party in a friend's loft recall the
roommates the self-made art and photos
on the walls the obscenely cheap rent
the happiness and simplicity of it all
step 11 quickly create a list of the top
10 things you own in terms of how much
they cost with horror make a second list
of the top 10 things that make you happy
since the creeping dread as you realize
there's no overlap between the two
shudder step 12 decide to have a packing
party like your friends suggested one
time take the old sheets you never use
from cratenbarrel cover all your stuff
with them endeavor not to uncover it
unless you decide you need to use it
suddenly realize he will never use
anything because you are never home step
13 remember a time in childhood when you
were more excited by ideas love travel
and people than by anything else realize
you have somehow bought into a new
religion and that malls from the inside
look exactly like cathedrals step 14
consider starting a fire step 15
consider that perhaps you are more than
just your stuff begin to take a long
walk breathe step 16 begin to relax give
yourself the freedom to begin to dream
again a well-edited life by Joshua
fields Melbourne everyone develops their
own creative process over time some
sculptors bernini for instance build
sculptures with clay others like
Michelangelo carved from marble though
I'm no Michelangelo my creative process
tends to mimic the ladder building way
too much and then removing massive
amounts of excess until I uncover the
beauty beneath the banality I call this
process subtractive creation unlike most
carving sculptors though I also have to
quarry the marble from which I pitch
chisel and polish the essays on our
website are published with around 400
words even though they often start with
2,000 or more my novel was 950 pages
before it entered the world with only
252 the bookie reading now was 700 pages
at its bloated apex now as fewer than
half when I edit this way the final
result is far more meaningful to me and
to the reader
the care and handcrafted NIST shows in
the final work I teach my writing
students how to edit this way to that is
how to spend one third of their time
writing effectively and two thirds of
their time editing shaping their work
into something more concise more
powerful more beautiful subtractive
creation seems to be an appropriate
metaphor for the rest of life as well
there will always be life's XS always
more almost too many inputs bombarding
us from every direction but instead of
abhorrent multitasking instead of trying
to get things done we can make life more
beautiful via subtraction we can filter
out the noise we can remove unnecessary
material possessions we can let go of
sentimental items we can get rid of
negative relationships we can avoid the
American dream and when everyone is
looking for more we can focus on less
sure there's an infinite amount of
materials with which to build our lives
but sometimes the best way to build is
to subtract the best lives are often
well edited carefully curated lives PS
yes I know Bernini also sculpted with
marble
you are not impressing me our please
like me culture has transformed into
something hideous
we've been enveloped by an epidemic of
pointless attention-grabbing solipsism
look around the world is attempting to
impress you we needn't impress anyone
and yet we all try relentlessly we try
doing the strangest things to get the
attention and ultimately the approval of
others oh you purchased a brand-new
Lexus you're a published author your job
title is X and you earn six figures so
what take it from two guys who had it
all who had to get everything we ever
wanted to realize that everything we
ever wanted wasn't what we wanted at all
it was empty meaningless depressing your
material possessions your social status
and even your so-called accomplishments
don't impress anyone they certainly
don't impress us
you impress us not the things around you
we are impressed by your commitment to
change by your ability to grow by a
desire to contribute beyond yourself
everything else is just a social
construct devoid a meaning there's
nothing inherently wrong with owning
possessions accomplishing goals or
earning money just don't think those
things impress anyone they don't at
least not in a meaningful way I counted
all my stuff the most unfortunate
misconception we encounter about
minimalism has to do with the act of
counting your possessions I could never
be a minimalist because I don't want to
live with less than a hundred things we
hear that a lot
even well-regarded internet stars
inadvertently promulgate this
misconception saying odd things like I'm
not a minimalist
I have no desire to move to a 300 square
foot apartment and religiously track the
number of socks I own yeah and neither
do we seeing people propagate such
misconceptions is unfortunate because it
gives an important movement to black eye
and scares people away from something
greater often the people promoting such
ideas do so without malice but they do
so because they are afraid of labels but
some labels are helpful minimalism has
helped thousands of people discover
meaning in their lives it has never been
about counting stuff even our friend
Dave Bruno the author of the 100 thing
challenge would be the first person to
attest to this Dave lived for a long
time with only a hundred things as a
personal challenge but the reason he did
so was to prove our call
consumption is void of meaning but the
number of possessions is arbitrary as a
parodic take on why counting isn't
necessary joshua counted his stuff last
year that si everything I owned my 288
things
the minimalist calm for / 288 he is
ironically one of the most popular
essays on our site the ostensible
subject counting your possessions was
not the true subject it was not the
point
the point was that taking a physical
inventory of your life is eye-opening
and it helps you get rid of unnecessary
items so you can appreciate what you
have you don't have to count your stuff
although you can if you want
either way minimalism can help you live
more and need less irrespective of how
many pairs of socks you own
start with the easy stuff baffled by
life's excess we often look around at
our piles of miscellanea and throw our
hands in the air there's so much emotion
so many memories wrapped up in our
possessions although of course the
memories aren't in the possessions
they're inside us and that's where
they'll always be but still letting go
is difficult difficult but not
impossible want to start simplifying
first avoid sentimental items and
difficult to part with objects you'll
never get started if you're faced with
all that heavy lifting and stay away
from the most onerous rooms basements
garages and attic they will only
overwhelm you instead start with the
easy things the superfluous clothes
jammed in the closet the junk drawers
teeming with junk the unused kitchen
we're taking up space just in case if
you begin with the things that are
painless then as inertia takes over
simplifying gets easier by the day
moreover the journey toward a simpler
life is more enjoyable with an
accountability partner a new month is
always peeking his head around the
corner which means it's the perfect time
to play the thirty-day minimalism game
the minimalist calm forward-slash game
so grab a friend clear the clutter and
have some fun together
letting go of sentimental items by
Joshua fields Melbourne my mother died
in 2009 she lived a thousand miles away
and was my responsibility to vacate her
apartment in Florida it was a small
one-bedroom place but it was packed
wall-to-wall with her belongings mom had
great tastes she could have been an
interior designer and none of her stuff
was junk nevertheless there was a lot of
stuff in her home mom was constantly
shopping I was accumulating more stuff
she had antique furniture throughout her
apartment
a stunning oak canopy bed that consumed
almost her entire bedroom two closets
jam-packed with clothes picture frames
standing on every flat surface original
artwork adoring the walls and tasteful
decorations in every nook cranny and
crevice there was 64 years of
accumulation in that apartment so I did
what any son would do I rented a large
truck from u-haul then I called a
storage place back in Ohio to make sure
they had a big enough storage unit the
truck was $1,600 the storage facility
was $120 financially I could afford it
but I quickly found out the emotional
cost was much higher at first I didn't
want to let go of anything if you've
ever lost a parent a loved one or been
through a similarly emotional time did
you understand exactly how hard it was
for me to let go of any of those
possessions so instead of letting go I
wanted to cram every trinket figurine
and piece of oversized furniture into
that storage locker in Ohio floor to
ceiling that way I knew that mom's stuff
was there if I ever wanted it if I ever
needed access to it for some
incomprehensible reason I even planned
to put a few pieces of mom's furniture
in my home as subtle reminders of her I
started boxing up her belongings every
picture frame every porcelain doll and
every white doily on every shelf I
packed every bit of her that remained or
so I thought I looked under her bed
among the organized chaos that
compromised the crawl space beneath her
bed there were four boxes each labeled
with a number each number box was sealed
with packing tape I cut through the tape
and found old papers from my elementary
school days from nearly a quarter
century ago spelling tests cursive
writing lessons artwork it was all there
every shred of paper from my first four
years of school it was evident she had
access to sealed boxes in years yet mom
had held on to these two
because she was trying to hold on to
pieces of me pieces of the past much
like I was attempting to hold on to
pieces of her and her past I realized my
retention efforts were futile I could
hold on to her memories without her
stuff just as she had always remembered
me my childhood and all our memories
without ever accessing those sealed
boxes under her bed she didn't need
papers from 25 years ago to remember me
just as I didn't need a storage locker
filled with her stuff to remember her
I called u-haul and cancelled the truck
and then over the next 12 days I donated
her stuff to places and people who could
use it of course it was difficult to let
go but I realized many things about our
relationship between memories and
possessions during the entire experience
I am NOT my stuff we are more than our
possessions our memories are within us
not within our things holding on to
stuff imprisons us letting go is freeing
you can take pictures of items you want
to remember old photographs can be
scanned an item that is sentimental for
us can be useful for someone else
I don't think sentimental items are bad
or evil or that holding onto them is
wrong I don't I think the danger of
sentimental items and sentimentality in
general is far more subtle if you want
to get rid of an item but the only
reason you are holding on to it is for
sentimental reasons if it is weighing on
you then perhaps it's time to get rid of
it perhaps it's time to free yourself of
the weight that doesn't mean you need to
get rid of everything though when I
returned to Ohio I had four boxes and
mom's photographs in my trunk
which I would later scan and back up
online I found a scanner that made
scanning the photos easy
the minimalist comm forward-slash
scanning those photos are digital now
and they can be used in digital picture
frames instead of collecting dust in a
basement I no longer have the clutter of
their boxes lying around and weighing me
down and they can never be destroyed in
a fire I donated everything else strewn
throughout her home her furniture her
clothes and her decorative items it was
a giant leap for me but I felt it must
be done to remove the weight the
emotional gravitas of the situation from
my shoulders
I don't need mom's stuff to remind me of
her there are traces of her everywhere
in the way I act in the way I treat
others even in the way I smile she's
still there she was never a part of her
stuff whenever I give advice I'm paring
down I tend to
you have two options the first option is
usually the giant leap option the dive
in headfirst option eg get rid of
everything smash your TV throughout all
your stuff quickly rip off the band-aid
etc this option isn't for everyone and
it's often not for me but in this case
that's what I did I donated everything
the second option is to take baby steps
it works because it helps he build
momentum by taking action what's that
metal item can you get rid of today that
you've wanted to get rid of for a while
start there then pick a one or two
things per week and gradually increase
your efforts as you feel more
comfortable whichever option you choose
take action
never leave the scene of a good idea
without taking action packing party
unpack a simpler life by Ryan Nicodemus
what makes a rich person rich when I was
a teenager I thought it was fifty
thousand dollars a year when I started
climbing the corporate ladder in my
early 20s I soon earned fifty grand
something was wrong though I didn't feel
rich so I went back to the drawing board
and discovered my error I forgot to
adjust for inflation
maybe 75 thousand dollars a year was
rich maybe ninety thousand dollars maybe
six figures or maybe owning a bunch of
stuff maybe that was rich
whatever rich was I knew that once I got
there I'd finally be happy so as I made
more money I spent more money all in the
pursuit of the American dream all in the
pursuit of happiness but the closer I
got the further away happiness was five
years ago my life was different from
what it is today
radically different I had everything I
ever wanted everything I was quote
unquote supposed to have I had an
impressive job title at respectable
corporation a successful career managing
dozens of employees
I earned a six-figure income I bought a
shiny new car every few years
I owned a huge three-bedroom
two-bathroom 2,000 square foot condo it
even had two living rooms other than
maintaining several play rooms for my
cats I have no idea why a single guy
needs two living rooms my cat and I were
living the American dream everyone
around me said I was successful but I
was only ostensibly successful you see I
also had a bunch of things that were
hard to see from the outside even though
I earned a lot of money
I had heaps of debt chasing the American
dream
me a lot more than money my life was
filled with stress anxiety and
discontent I was miserable
I may have looked successful but I
certainly didn't feel successful it got
to a point where I didn't know what was
important anymore but one thing was
clear there was a gaping void in my life
so I tried to fill that void the same
way many people do with stuff lots of
stuff I attempted to fill the void with
consumer purchases I bought new cars new
electronics and new expensive clothes I
bought expensive furniture home
decorations and all the latest gadgets
why I didn't have enough cash in the
bank I paid for expensive meals rounds
of drinks and frivolous vacations with
credit cards I spent money faster than I
earned it an attempt to buy my way to
happiness and I thought I'd get there in
one day happiness had to be just around
the corner but the stuff didn't fill the
void it widened it because I didn't know
what was important I continued to fill
the void with stuff going further into
debt working hard to buy things that
weren't making me happy this went on for
years and demoralizing cycle by my late
20s my life on the outside looked great
but inside I was a mess how several
years divorced I was unhealthy I felt
stuck I drank a lot
I did drugs a lot I used as many
pacifiers as I could and I continued to
work 6070 sometimes 80 hours a week
forsaking the most important aspects of
my life I barely ever thought about my
health my relationships my passions
worst of all I felt stagnant I wasn't
growing and I certainly wasn't
contributing to others my life lacked a
meaning purpose passion if you would
have asked me what I was passionate
about I would have looked at you like a
deer in the headlights what am i
passionate about I had no idea I was
living paycheck to paycheck living for a
paycheck living for stuff living for a
career I didn't love I wasn't really
living at all though I was depressed
then as I was approaching age 30 I
noticed something different about my
best friend of 20 years
Josh seemed happy for the first time in
a long time like truly happy ecstatic
but why we had worked side by side at
the same corporation throughout our 20s
both climbing the ranks and he had been
just as miserable as me something
significant had changed
to boot he had just gone through two of
the most difficult events of his life
his mother just passed away and his
marriage had ended both in the same
month he wasn't supposed to be happy and
he definitely wasn't supposed to be
happier than me so I did what any good
friend would do I bought him lunch at a
fine dining establishment we went to
Subway while we were eating our
sandwiches I asked Josh why the hell are
you so happy
Josh spent the next 20 minutes telling
me about something called minimalism he
talked about how he'd spent the last few
months simplifying his life getting the
clutter out of the way to make room for
what was truly important and then he
showed me an entire community of people
who had done the same thing he
introduced me to a guy named Colin right
a 24-year old entrepreneur who travels
to a new country every four months
carrying with him everything he owns
then there was Joshua Becker a 36 year
old husband and father of two with a
full time job in a car and a house and
suburban Vermont next he showed me corny
Carver a 40 year old wife and mother to
a teenage daughter in Salt Lake City and
there was Leo Bovada a 38 year old
husband and father of six in San
Francisco although all these people led
considerably different lives they all
shared at least two things in common
first they were living deliberate
meaningful lives they were passionate
Purpose Driven and they seemed much
richer than any of the so-called rich
guys I worked with in the corporate
world second they all attributed their
improved lives to this thing called
minimalism so being the problem solver I
am I decided to become a minimalist
right there on the spot
I looked up at Josh and excitedly
announced all right I'm in I'm a
minimalist now what you see I didn't
want to spend months slowly paring down
my possessions like Josh had that was
fine for him but I needed faster results
so we came up with a crazy idea let's
throw a packing party everything is more
fun when he put party at the end we
decided to pack all my belongings as if
I were moving and then I would unpack
only the items I needed over the next
three weeks Josh came over helped me box
up everything my clothes my kitchen
where my towels my electronics my TV's
my frame photographs and paintings my
toiletries even my furniture everything
we literally pretended I was moving
after nine hours and a few pizza
deliveries everything
was packed there we were sitting in my
second living room feeling exhausted
staring at boxes stacked halfway to my
12-foot ceiling my condo was empty and
everything smelled like cardboard
everything I owned every single thing
I'd worked for over the past decade was
there in that room boxes stacked on top
of boxes stacked on top of boxes each
box was labeled so nowhere to go when I
needed a particular item labels like
living room junk drawer number one
kitchen utensils bedroom closet shrunk
drawer number seven and so on I spent
the next 21 days unpacking only the
items I needed my toothbrush my bed and
bed sheets clothes for work the
furniture I actually used kitchenware a
tool set just the things that added
value to my life
after three weeks 80% of my stuff was
still in those boxes just sitting there
on accessed I looked at those boxes and
I couldn't remember what was in most of
them all those things that were supposed
to make me happy weren't doing their job
so I sold some of it and then donated
the rest and you know what I started to
feel rich for the first time in my life
I felt rich once I got everything out of
the way so I can make room for
everything that remains
photo scanning party by Joshua fields
Melbourne if you're gonna ask for one
physical gift this year for the holidays
consider a good photo scanner if you're
like me then you've probably let the
overstuffed boxes and photo albums go
and checked over the years and now
they're collecting dust in your basement
or closet unused just sitting there
waiting for one day to come one day two
of the most dangerous words in the
English language I to eldan to heaps of
meaningful photos to added no value to
my life because they were hidden away
and the prospect of dealing with them
seemed daunting
overwhelming not worth the hassle so I
let them sit in the Attic the cupboard
the garage then inspired by Ryan's
packing party I decided to throw a photo
scanning party it turns out that if he
put party at the end of anything Ryan
will show up first
I found a high-quality scanner the
minimalist com forward slash scanning
that allows me to rapidly feed photos
and immediately save them to a memory
card which I could then use in a couple
high-res digital picture frames what a
novel idea actually display my treasured
photos Plus if anything were to happen
to my home flood fire robbery all my
photos are backed up online that's I'll
never worry about losing those memories
of course the memories aren't in our
material possessions but I found that a
well curated photo collection can help
trigger all the wonderful memories of
yesteryear without all the physical
baggage next to make my party a little
more fun and less lonely I invited a few
friends over ordered food and drinks and
together we thumb through the
photographs of my childhood and all of
its double-chin grandeur scanning my
favourites to display I have one
remaining box of photos I'm going to
scan this month
I think another scanning party is in
order feel free to join me scan your own
photos and share some of your favorites
on Twitter or Instagram using our
scanning party hashtag
getting rid of just-in-case items we
often hold on to things just in case we
need them we don't let go because we
might need something in some far-off
non-existent hypothetical future and we
pack too much stuff for trips and
vacations just in case we needn't hold
on to these things just in case the
truth is we rarely use our just in case
items and so they sit there take up
space get in the way weigh us down most
of the time they aren't items we need at
all instead if we remove the just in
case items from our lives we can get
them out of the way we can free up the
space they consume over the last few
years the two of us let go of the vast
majority of our just in case possessions
and during our last tour we made sure we
did pack anything just in case and then
we tested our theory the 20/20 rule
anything we get rid of that we truly
need we can replace for less than twenty
dollars in less than twenty minutes from
our current location thus far this
theory has held true 100% of the time
although we've rarely had to replace a
just-in-case item fewer than five times
for the two of us combined we've never
had to pay more than $20 or go more than
twenty minutes out of our way to replace
the item this theory likely works 99% of
the time for 99% of all items and 99% of
all people including you more important
we haven't missed the hundreds of just
incase items we've gotten rid of and we
didn't need to replace most of them
getting rid of these items clears one's
mind frees up their space and takes the
weight off his or her shoulders what are
you holding on to just in case 9090 rule
rules can be arbitrary restrictive
boring but they are often helpful when
we hope to make a change whenever we
attempt to simplify our lives we often
get stuck before we get started when
faced with a hoard of possessions some
useful others not it is difficult to
determine what serves a purpose and what
we're holding on to just in case which
makes letting go nearly impossible
without some sort of rules to move us in
the right direction here's one that has
worked for us look at a possession pick
something anything have you used that
item in the last 90 days if you haven't
will you use it in the next 90 if not
then it's okay to let go maybe your rule
is an
days maybe it's honor in 20 maybe it's
six months whatever your rule be honest
with yourself if your material
possessions don't bring you joy then
they are likely in the way of a more
intentional life when everything is your
favorite thing by Joshua fields
Melbourne when you get rid of most of
your stuff your life invariably changes
without all the things in your way you
have the opportunity to focus on the
most important aspects of your life but
there was also an unexpected benefit
from my newly uncluttered life now I
truly enjoy everything I own
before I embrace minimalism I had a lot
of stuff a three-bedroom house teeming
with stuff a basement and a two-car
garage filled with boxes overflowing
with stuff spare bedrooms and closets
and cabinets jam-packed with stuff every
nook every cranny more stuff it was hard
to keep track of it and all that stuff
added very little value to my life it
often just made me feel anxious
overwhelmed and depressed I was unhappy
with the way I felt so I started
questioning everything I owned today I
don't own much but the things I do own
add immense value to my life when I got
rid of my extraneous material
possessions what remained were the
things I use everyday
now nearly everything I own is my
favourite thing all my clothes are my
favourite clothes all my furniture is my
favourite furniture all my possessions
are my favourite possessions all of
which I enjoy every day of my life how
about you what if you enjoyed everything
you owned how would it make you feel if
you were surrounded by your favourite
things every day
favourite clothes of a minimalist by
Joshua fields Melbourne quote look at
all those fancy clothes but these gonna
keep us warm just like those Jack
Johnson what does a minimalist wear I'm
surprised I get this question as often
as I do as that people expect to see me
walking around in a loincloth
but given the many misconceptions
surrounding minimalism I suppose it's a
valid question my answer a minimalist
where's his or her favorite clothes
every day most days I wear jeans a
t-shirt and a pair of boots or when I
feel like it I wear a crisp white
button-up shirt jeans a blazer colorful
socks and a clean pair of dress shoes I
avoid logos because they don't enjoy
being a walking billboard I don't have
many clothes now and I still go to the
goodwill a few times a month to donate
an EIN number to if I'm not wearing it
anymore it gets donated but I thoroughly
enjoy the clothes I own I don't however
give sentimental meaning to my clothes
if all my clothes burned in a house fire
tomorrow it wouldn't be a big deal to me
quote what about those shoes you're in
today they'll do no good on the bridges
you burnt along the way Jack Johnson
spill bleach on your wardrobe by Joshua
fields Melbourne what if you spilled
bleach on half your wardrobe what would
you do some hypothetical questions are
so ridiculous we dismissed them as
absurd laughable queries sadly though
the above question is not purely
hypothetical after returning home from
the final leg of our recent tour
fatigues and murky headed from cross
country traversing I separated my dirty
laundry into appropriate piles prepping
each color-coded assemblage for his
usual rinse and spin cycles then
unknowingly and stupidly I spilled a
bottle of liquid bleach on literally
half the clothes staining the floor
strewn heaps instantly ruining the
majority of my wardrobe I was shocked by
two things first I was shocked by my
brain lessness how could I make such a
ridiculous mistake
she was be told I simply wasn't paying
attention there's no other explanation
if there's a lesson to be learned here
it's that attention must be paid even
during the most mundane tasks second I
was shocked I wasn't more horrified by
my idiotic mistake I should be outraged
right two years ago I would have been
pissed I would have fumed angrily and
curse the ceiling and hurled various
breakable objects at one or more of my
apartments walls but last week a sodium
hypochlorite soaked through my threads I
didn't react obnoxiously instead I
realized I couldn't control everything I
took a few deep breaths snatched a mop
from my closet and start cleaning the
mess I'd made the sooner we clean up our
mess
the sooner we can move on with life sure
half my attire is ruined but
everything's fine I'll replace some of
the clothes if I need to but my closet
isn't upset and nor should I be those
clothes were just clothes
replaceable things that don't have any
more meaning than the meaning I give to
them there's no case in crying over
spilt milk or in this case spilt bleach
things we walk away from by Joshua
fields Melbourne what are you prepared
to walk away from this often asked
question shapes one of the most
important principles in my life we are
all familiar with the age-old
theoretical situation in which our home
is burning and we must grab only the
things that are most important to us of
course most of us will not dash into the
inferno and reach for material things
first
we'd ensure the safety of our loved ones
and pets then once they were safe we
grab
only the irreplaceable things photo
albums computer hard drives family
heirlooms everything else would be lost
in the configuration I tend to look at
this situation a tad differently though
taking the hypothetical a bit further
there's a scene in heat in which Neel
McCauley Robert DeNiro says quote allow
nothing in your life that you cannot
walk out on in 30 seconds flat
unquote although my life isn't anything
like Macaulay's he's the movies bad guy
I share his sentiment almost everything
I bring into my life material
possessions ideas habits and even
relationships I must be able to walk
away from at a moment's notice many of
you will disagree with me because this
ideology might sound crass or
insensitive but I like to posit that it
is actually the opposite our
preparedness to walk away is the
ultimate form of caring if I purchase
new possessions I need to make certain I
don't assign them too much meaning being
able to walk away means I won't ever get
too attached to my belongings and being
unattached to stuff makes our lives
tremendously flexible filled with
opportunity if I take on a new idea or
habit I do so because it has the
potential to add value to my life
new ideas shape the future me same goes
for new habits over time my ideas change
improve and expand and my current habits
get replaced by new habits that continue
to help me grow our readiness to walk
away from ideas or habits means we're
willing to grow we're willing to
constantly pursue a better version of
ourselves if I bring a new relationship
into my world I know I must earn their
love respect and kindness
I also expect they too are willing to
walk away should I not provide the
support and understanding they require
this means we must both work hard to
contribute to the relationship we must
communicate and remain cognizant of each
other's needs and above all we must care
these fundaments love understanding
caring communication build trust which
builds stronger relationships in the
long run it sounds paradoxical but our
willingness to walk away actually
strengthens our bond with others and the
opposite stance being chained by
obligation to a relationship is
disingenuous a false loyalty bird from
pious plication there are obvious
exceptions to this rule there are
certain things we cannot easily walk
away from a marriage a business
partnership a job that pays the rent
the key is to have as few exceptions as
possible naturally even these exceptions
aren't exceptions for everyone marriages
often end as do businesses people get
laid off and passions change over time
even though we might not be able to walk
away from these things in 30 seconds
flat we can ultimately walk away when
these situations no longer add value to
our lives or worse when they drain value
from our lives everything I allow into
my life enters it deliberately if my
home was a flame there's nothing I own
that can't be replaced all my photos are
scanned all my important files are
backed up and all my stuff has no real
meaning similarly I'm prepared to walk
away from nearly anything even our
websites teaching or writing if need be
doing so safeguards my continued growth
and improves my relationships with
others both of which contribute to a
fulfilling life a life of meaning it was
CS Lewis who fifty years ago
eloquently said quote don't let your
happiness depend on something you may
lose unquote in today's material world a
world of fear fueled clinging his words
seemed more apropos than ever home is
where the red phone is by Joshua fields
Melbourne
I don't enjoy travelling as much as some
people unless I'm touring which I'm
doing at the time of this writing which
I enjoy because the people are amazing I
tend to avoid exorbitant travel opting
instead to stay home in my community
most of the time all my clothes will
likely fit in a single suitcase but I
don't enjoy living out of a suitcase I
find value in traversing the globe in
discovering new cultures and learning
more about myself in the process but I
truly enjoy living in a home a place I
can call my own
the problem with homes however is once
we establish a long-term dwelling it's
easy to accumulate a bunch of junk we
don't need I built my first house when I
was 22 a feat that seems ridiculous now
but its size was even more ridiculous
and contained three bedrooms even though
only my former spouse and I lived there
it had a huge basement which was a great
place to hide last month's to start a
new possessions toys I no longer played
with it featured not only a gigantic
living room but also an entertainment
room which i think is pretty much just a
fancy way to say room with a two large
TV and expensive surround sound system
we think we have to fill all our space
every corner no can hidden cranny
crammed with
ornaments we believe if a room is nearly
empty then it is underutilized so we buy
stuff
silly stock paintings decorative
thingies and IKEA furniture to fill the
void what we're doing is attempting to
establish the place in which we live as
our home an extension of ourselves and
so the logic goes the more I buy the
more this place is my home the problem
with this line of thinking is its secure
this your home is your home for one
reason you call it your home the stuff
doesn't make it your home you do if you
need a reminder you can do what I do
find one thing something unique and
display it somewhere prominent for me
it's a red phone a relic from my 12
years in the telecom industry it's a
simple beautiful design that stands out
the same phone is in the Museum of
Modern Art and whenever I see it I know
I'm home for you your red phone could be
a one-of-a-kind painting a photograph
child's frame drawing when you have a
single reminder of home everything else
begins to look superfluous even silly
what is your red phone I don't love you
anymore
by Joshua Fields Milburn there weren't
any tears during my most recent breakup
no possessions strewn across the lawn no
passive aggression no yelling fighting
or angry text messages there's only a
twinge of relief an unexpected paying of
freedom the moment it all ended I just
stood there in awkward silence between
us when I finally hand her the bag of
clothes I knew there was no turning back
but her features held no sign of sadness
more like a look of gratitude as I drove
away I didn't once look in the rearview
thankfully this estrangement wasn't with
a person but with a large chunk of my
wardrobe if I would have
anthropomorphised that bag of clothes
before I handed it to the pretty girl at
Goodwill I would have told it quote it's
not you hell it's not even me
it's us we're no longer right for each
other I just don't love you anymore
unquote I realize it was time for us to
part ways just last week after I pulled
on a t-shirt and immediately wanted to
wear something else it was a decent
shirt when I got a lot of use out of but
I didn't love wearing it anymore and I
hadn't loved wearing it in a while so I
decided to go through my already minimal
closet and dump every item I didn't love
I'd rather own just a few outfits
outfits I enjoy wearing
I feel confident in a wardrobe that
brings me joy then a mediocre collection
of once loved threads sometimes loved
sunders and we must move on the things
we once loved we may not love forever
a Rolex won't give you more time by
Joshua fields Melbourne a friend
recently emailed me to communicate the
buyer's remorse he was experiencing
after purchasing an expensive watch even
though he's a successful entrepreneur
who can afford to drop ten thousand
dollars on shiny wrist ornamentation he
expressed pains of post purchase grief
sorrow and regret he wasn't entirely
sure why he felt this way so he emailed
me for advice this is how I responded I
know where you're coming from as guy who
has owned several expensive watches I
owned more than one fancy watch during
my Lotus eating 20s although I don't own
one now I understand the allure I could
of course recite a dozen platitudes here
an expensive watch can give you more
time a puppet who enjoys the string
still isn't free you are not the sum of
your material possessions our
possessions possess us etc but it comes
down to two things value and quality of
life in terms of value does the watch
actually add value to your life or does
it drain value I'm not talking about
monetary value prices and arbitrary
measurement I'm talking real intrinsic
value is that watch worth $10,000 of
your freedom is it worth the emotional
stress you're going through while
thinking about it I know these questions
sound rhetorical but they're not I'm
currently wearing a hundred dollar pair
of jeans and yes they are worth a
hundred dollars of my freedom to me
they are also my only pair of jeans
therefore I get immense value from them
since I wear them almost every day does
the watch do the same for you if so
where with pride if it doesn't then ask
yourself why you still own it not why
you bought it but why you still own it
is it a status thing is it part of your
identity is it just an expensive
personal logo at this point the purchase
is over you needn't beat yourself up
over it because you can't change it it's
a sunk cost but you can change what you
do going forward if you're not getting
value from the purchase if you get value
from the watch if it truly enhances your
life then why not keep it and when it
comes to quality of life you need to
consider how the watch adds to the
quality of your life
I used to earn about two
thousand dollars a year at the peak of
my corporate days but I was miserable my
quality of life was poor last year
however at age 31
I made $27,000 which is actually less
than I earned at 18 but with that
$27,000 I still saved more than I've
ever saved paid off the rest of my debt
traveled more than I've ever traveled
and experienced life real life more than
ever before though I make a multiplicity
of millions less than the corporate
bigwigs I once aspired to be and though
I bring home roughly 1/8 of what I used
to bring home at my pinnacle
I hope really higher quality of life
than most CEOs and my former self
very few material possessions could
enhance that quality of life in fact
most would take away from it I obviously
cannot and will not tell you what to do
with your shiny timepiece what I can
tell you is I'm much happier without my
expensive watches who needs to know the
time all the time anyway I got rid of
two thousand bucks by Joshua fields
Melbourne I used to own 2,000 books
slightly more than that actually I had
all kinds of books hardcovers paperbacks
trade paperbacks literary fiction
writing and grammar books books of
photography self-help books my deceased
father's collection of old medical
journals genre fiction does cute little
pop-up books you name it I had shelves
and shelves and more shelves of books
some of which ought to actually read and
many of which I'd read someday you know
whenever I got around to it who was I
kidding I thought my overflowing shelves
of books maybe look important
intelligent and cool look at me I know
how to read a lot what's worse I thought
these books made me somebody they were
part of my identity those books were a
part of me and want some things a part
of your identity once it becomes a part
of you it's exceedingly hard to shed
this is true for anything we incorporate
into our identities our careers our cars
our homes our possessions our
sentimental items these things become
part of us and they become anchors in
our lives anchors that keep us at bay
away from the freedom of the open seas
ironically three quotes from a
particular book I owned Chuck Palahniuk
Fight Club or what inspired me to get
rid of the vast majority my books a
little over a year ago quote reject the
basic assumptions of civilization a
especially the importance of material
possessions quote the things you own end
up owning you quote it's only after
we've lost everything that we're free to
do anything
unquote these words resonate with me
deeply
I could feel on my nerve endings why
Palahniuk was saying I read those quotes
several times and within a week sold or
donated ninety-eight percent of my books
I purchased a Kindle and kept one shelf
of my favorite physical books some older
books aren't yet on Kindle which is a
shame in those rare cases I'll get the
book elsewhere a public library a local
independent bookstore online and when
I'm finished reading it I'll often
donate it I no longer own piles of books
but I read more than before I enjoy each
book taking them in slowly absorbing the
knowledge processing the information
contemplating their lessons but I need
and retain the physical book to get
value from its words think about it how
much value was I placing in all the
books I owned obviously was far more
than their real value the real value was
in the words an action of reading not in
the physical books themselves
letting go of your DVD collection are
you one of those people who collects
DVDs proudly displaying your stockpile
on a wall shelf or special area
designated for your dozens of favorite
movies have you thought about why you
own all those DVDs do you really plan to
rewatch the same movies three four or a
dozen times both of us had fairly
sizable DVD collections before taking
our journeys into minimalism we wasted
thousands of dollars on these
collections often purchasing movies we'd
already seen and then we allowed our
extensive collections to collect dust or
we'd occasionally rewatch a movie living
in the past attempting to reconstruct an
old moment instead of creating new ones
but collecting is just hoarding with a
prettier name don't believe us look it
up the Oxford American writers thesaurus
lists the following synonyms under the
first definition of collection horde
pile heap stock pile
yes collecting things you don't need
things you don't get value from is
tantamount to hoarding the two of us
still watch movies but we watch new
movies creating new experiences in our
lives we strengthen our relationships by
enjoying movies with friends we grow by
talking about those experiences after
they happen developing a better
understanding of ourselves in the
process let go of that DVD collection
you can sell it and make some money and
stop watching the same things over and
over live your life instead there is an
entire world out there and there's so
much value you can add to that world so
much you can contribute beyond yourself
or certain of it or how about this keep
the movies that add value to your life
there's nothing wrong with an occasional
rerun no glanced in the rearview but
then look forward and let go of the rest
more is less less is more we all know
this saying first popularized by
minimalist architect - Ludwig Mies van
der Rohe a--
which has been transformed into a
platitude by advertisers TV shows and
even corporate America as it right sizes
people out of their livelihoods quote
will have to learn to do more with less
around here unquote but is less really
more and if so is the opposite true is
more actually less questions like this
may be more important than you think the
two of us enjoy taking commonly accepted
truisms and trite stock phrases and
flipping them on their axes exploring
the other side of cliches and hackneyed
phrases shedding light on the opposite
sides of supposed facts for example what
moniker does our culture often assigned
to a well-adjusted ostensibly successful
person we often say that these people
are anchored quote he is such an
anchored person unquote we heard this
term frequently during our late 20s
we were regularly described as anchored
people the longest time we took this as
a compliment then we stopped taking it
at face value and asked what is an
anchor that question led us to an
important discovery about our lives an
anchor is a theme that keeps a ship at
bay planted in the harbor stuck in one
place unable to explore the freedom of
the sea perhaps we were angered we knew
we weren't happy with our lives and
perhaps being incurred wasn't
necessarily a good thing in the course
of time we each identified our own
personal anchors circumstances keeping
us from realizing real freedom and found
they were plentiful joshua catalogued
eighty-three anchors Ryan 54 we
discovered big anchors debts bad
relationships etc and small anchors
superfluous bills material possessions
etc and in time we eliminated the vast
majority of those anchors one by one
documenting our experience and our first
book minimalism live a meaningful life
it turned out being anchored was a
terrible thing it kept us from leading
the lives we wanted to lead not all our
anchors were bad but the vast majority
prevented us from encountering lasting
contentment are you an anchored person
is that a good thing what are some of
your anchors and what other axioms might
you want to question which brings us
back to our original set of questions is
less really more if so is more actually
less we suggest an answer to both is yes
owning less stuff focusing on fewer
tasks and having less in the way has
given us more time more freedom and more
meaning in our lives working less allows
us to contribute more grow more and
pursue our passions much more having
more time causes less frustration and
less stress more freedom as less anxiety
and less worry and more meaning in our
lives allows us to focus far less on
life's excess in favor what's truly
important so more is less yes more or
less
funnily
here are some voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners hi this is
Jennifer I'm calling from Philadelphia
Pennsylvania and I was actually calling
in response to what you guys were saying
about gift-giving especially in
consideration to wedding or baby showers
and I think that giving a gift of cash
is great but sometimes that does feel a
little I would prefer to give them a
gift as well so I actually have the
habit of giving people a thoughtful care
package full of things that the couple
of parents might need so for example my
friends were traveling internationally
for their honeymoon so I packed a travel
satchel with travel sized hand sanitizer
lotion painkillers and acids and base
tissues basically anything that you
would probably need on a vacation but
that you might neglect to bring where
that might be difficult to find
especially in a foreign country I feel
like it's a nice addition to the gift of
a cash or cheque and it gives them
something that I think would be of good
value to them and the same thing goes
with a baby shower giving somebody a
gift card or cash but then also giving
them diapers and formula and things that
they're definitely going to need that
might not be as exciting as the gifts
that are on the registry but would
definitely bring a lot of value hitties
awesome Ryan my name is Nikki horn and
I'm actually calling from fort st. Lucie
Florida I don't know there's a lot of
people out there that struggle with
anxiety I'm sure there are a lot of
people may not just want to admit it but
I do struggle with anxiety and I notice
that when I am constantly flooded with
social media or television or just too
much noise like you guys were talking
about I get very overwhelmed
so our really big thing for me was
literally turning off all of my
notifications on my phone and when I
still found myself having the urge to go
on to the different social media sites
what I actually did was I just removed
the apps altogether from my
and that helps me tremendously I also do
meditation and I've been enjoying baths
a lot more recently g'day Josh and Ryan
my name is Alisha and I'm from Adelaide
in Australia I just had to keep about
giftgiving my brother and I are both on
a mini Lizzie journey and Liz agreed to
give each other experiences or consumer
consumables as gifts and recently it was
his birthday so I took him for a walk up
Morial for Falls which is a beautiful
spot near us and I bought him some
birthday cake we're spending more
quality time together and it's really
awesome and want to thank you so much
for what you guys do listening to you
guys is really keeping me on track
during this silly season so Merry
Christmas all right Joe that's it for
this episode if you have a question for
the minimalists give us a call for zero
six two one nine seven eight three nine
and if you leave here with just one
message we hope it's this love people
and use things because the opposite
never works thanks for listening yeah
we'll see you next time
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without
[Music]
every little thing that you got a hand
every little thing that you got you
gotta reach for you gotta grab oh I bet
that you'll be fine without you
so tear your eyes or team
[Music]
you
[Music]